In this segment, we will
go through two examples
of maximum likelihood
estimation,
just in order to get a feel
for the procedure involved
and the calculations that
one has to go through.
Our first example
will be very simple.
We have a binomial
random variable
with parameters n and theta.
So think of having a coin
that you flip n times,
and theta is the
probability of heads
at each one of the tosses.
So we flip it n
times and we observe
a certain numerical
value, little k
for the random variable
K. And on the basis
of that numerical value, we
would like to estimate theta.
According to the maximum
likelihood methodology,
the first step is to write
down the likelihood function.
This is the probability of
obtaining this particular piece
of data if the true
parameter is theta.
Now, since K is a
binomial random variable,
the probability of obtaining
k heads in n tosses
is given by this
expression here.
So what we need to do is to take
the data that we have observed,
plug it in this formula,
leave theta free--
we have here a
function of theta--
and then maximize this function
of theta over all theta.
Let us now do this calculation.
Actually, instead of
maximizing this expression,
it's a little easier to
maximize the logarithm
of this expression.
And the logarithm of this
expression is as follows.
There's a first term, which
is the logarithm of the n
choose k term.
Then, the logarithm of theta
to the k is k times log theta.
And finally, the
logarithm of the last term
is n minus k, log
of 1 minus theta.
So we need to maximize this
expression with respect
to theta.
In order to do that, we take
the derivative with respect
to theta.
Here, there is no
theta involved.
We get a contribution of 0.
This term has a derivative
of k divided by theta.
And this term here
has a derivative,
which is n minus k
times the derivative
of this logarithmic
term, which is
1 over what is
inside the logarithm.
But by the chain rule,
because of this minus sign
here, we get also a minus sign,
and we obtain this expression.
Now, at the maximum,
the derivative
has to be equal to 0.
And this gives us now
an equation for theta
that we can solve.
Let us take this term, move
it to the right-hand side,
and then cross-multiply
with the denominators
to obtain the relation
that k minus k theta-- this
is obtained by multiplying this
k with this one minus theta
factor-- has to be equal to
this term times theta, which
is n times theta minus k theta.
The k theta terms
cancel, and we're
left with this
expression, which tells us
that theta should be
equal to k over n.
So this is the maximum
likelihood estimate
for this particular
problem, which
is a pretty reasonable answer.
If you would like to
rephrase what we just
found in terms of estimators
and random variables,
the maximum likelihood
estimator is as follows.
We take the random variable that
we observe, our observations,
and divide it by n.
And this is now a
random variable,
which will be our estimator.
Now, notice that in
this particular example,
the answer that we got is
exactly the same as the answer
that we got in the context
of Bayesian inference
when we were finding the
maximum a posteriori probability
estimator, but for
the special case
where the prior was a
uniform distribution.
So if we assume that theta
is actually a random variable
but has a uniform distribution,
so that we have a flat prior,
and we carry out maximum
a posteriori probability
estimation.
We do obtain exactly
the same estimate.
And this is consistent
with the comments
that we made earlier, that
maximum likelihood estimation
can be interpreted also as MAP
estimation with a flat prior.
Let us now move to our
second example, which
will be a little
more complicated.
Here, we have n random
variables that are independent,
identically distributed.
They all have a
normal distribution
with a certain
mean and variance.
But both the mean and
the variance are unknown,
and we want to estimate
them on the basis
of these observations.
The first step is to write
down the likelihood function.
That is the probability
density function
for the vector of observations
given some set of parameters.
Because of independence,
the joint distribution
of the vector of X's that we
have obtained is the product
of the PDFs of the
individual X's, of the Xi's.
So the PDF of the typical Xi
that has variance v and mean mu
is of this form.
So this is the likelihood
function in this case.
This is the probability
density of obtaining
a particular vector
X of observations
when we have these
particular parameters.
We would like to
maximize this function.
As in our previous example,
it is actually a little easier
to maximize the logarithm
of this expression.
And this is the
same as minimizing
the negative of the
logarithm of this expression.
Now, when we take the
logarithm of this expression,
we have a product.
So we're going to get
a sum of logarithms.
And I leave it to you to verify
that the negative logarithm
of this expression is of this
form plus some other constant
that does not involve
the parameters,
and which comes from this factor
of 1 over square root 2pi.
In particular, this
term here appears
when we take the
logarithm of this.
And this happens n times because
we have a product of n terms.
And this term here
appears when we
take the logarithm
of this expression,
and after we put
in the minus sign,
because we're
actually considering
the negative of the logarithm.
Now, to carry out the
minimization, what
we need to do is to take the
derivative of this expression
with respect to
mu, set it to zero,
and also take the
derivative with respect to v
and set it to zero as well.
Solve those equations and find
the optimal mu and v. So let's
start by optimizing
with respect to mu.
So we're going to take the
derivative of this expression
with respect to mu
and set it to zero.
This term does not
involve mu, so we only
need to take the
derivative of this.
And the derivative
of this is going
to be-- there's a term
1 over v. And then
the derivative of a
quadratic divided by 2
is just xi minus mu.
And we have one term
for each possible i.
We get this equation.
Now we can cancel out v, and
we're left with the equation
that the sum of the
xi's is equal to the sum
of the mus, which is n times mu.
And now we can send
n to the denominator
to obtain that
the estimate of mu
is going to be the sum
of the xi's divided by n.
So the maximum likelihood
estimate of the mean
takes a very simple
and very natural form.
It is just the sample mean.
Now, let us continue with
the minimization with respect
to v. In order to carry
out that minimization,
we need to take the derivative
of this expression with respect
to v and set it to zero.
The derivative of
the first term is
equal to n over 2 times 1
over v. And then from here,
when we take the
derivative, we obtain
the sum of all these terms
divided by 2v squared.
But actually, when we take
the derivative of 1 over v,
the derivative is
minus 1 over v squared.
And for this reason here,
we will have a minus sign.
So this is the
derivative with respect
to v. We set it equal to zero
and carry out some algebra.
What is the algebra
involved here?
We can delete this term, 2,
that appears here and there.
This term v cancels
out this exponent here.
Then we take this v, move
it to the other side,
and then take this n and
move it to this side,
underneath this term.
And finally, what we
obtain after you carry out
this algebra is this
expression, that the estimate
of the variance is some
form of the sample variance
where we use the
optimal value of mu.
And the optimal value of
mu we have already found.
It's given by this
expression here.
So we obtain a pretty natural
estimate for the variance
as well by using this maximum
likelihood methodology.
Now, these two examples
were particularly nice
because the algebra was
not too complicated.
And the answers
turned out to be what
you might have guessed without
using any fancy methods.
But in other problems,
the calculations
may be more complicated and the
answers may not be so obvious.